hello and welcome heather torres here
and i am so excited to invite you to our
exclusive training an inside look inside
of our inner circle our monthly online
business coaching program and we're
going to be deep diving into how to grow
on facebook now the first part of
today's training is going to be here on
side inside of the
facebook group for our inner circle as
well as live streaming on the youtube
channel so if you're watching on the
youtube channel hello and welcome to
this exclusive training and then the
second half is going to be an exclusive
q a and hot seats for our inner circle
but today i'm excited to jump into the
topic about growing on facebook now you
know here at think media we are shouting
from the rooftops that you should be
growing your uh brand and business on
youtube however as you start to excel
and grow that brand we want you to be
experimenting and dominating on other
platforms as well and so that includes
facebook but i have a question for you
do you think you're short on time and
you want to figure out how do you
actually do this thing on facebook like
how do i grow my following there and get
more leads that can lead to the right
customers in sales in today's training
we're going to be doing a deep dive into
helping you create a bank of content in
just a weekend you're gonna learn
exactly what's working uh right now on
facebook so you don't have to wonder
about what you should be posting you're
gonna master your promotional tactics so
you never have to uh think about what
should i be posting today well no it
will tell you exactly what to do and
you're going to learn how to scale your
facebook following without using ads or
without having to dance like on tick
tock unless you want to so i'm excited
because today we're also going to be um
featuring one of uh i think the most
profound teachers right now on facebook
which is my friend and expert rachel
miller we're gonna be diving into that
in just a second but you are here for
inner circle so welcome to our inner
circle and this is our number one
monthly group coaching program for
content creators who want to build a
high impact and a high profit online
business we believe in the power of
online business and we're excited to
bring today's training to you we're in a
social media series inside of our inner
circle because we know that as you grow
on youtube that you can also be growing
uh over on other platforms as well so
first we wanted to say thank you
thank you inner circle members that are
here right now watching live or on the
replay thank you for our think fam
that's over on the podcast channel
watching at this time we believe that
lifelong leaders are lifelong learners
thank you john maxwell and warren
buffett says that the best investment
that you can make is in yourself and so
for you watching this training today we
just want to say thank you for your time
thank you for being a part of our family
here and if you're not already
subscribed to the channel make sure
you're subscribed as well so uh we
wanted to make this the best training
that we can for you and as we walk
through inner circle we walk through our
ten steps and the ten steps to building
your six to seven figure media company
i'm excited to have uh get the guest
expert rachel miller here today because
she really is gonna help us with step
number eight which is promote and refine
your product and marketing and she's
really figured out how to market on
facebook and not just market on facebook
but grow an exceptional company on
facebook so we're going to be walking
through that step for you today here
inside of inner circle and like i said
we are inside of this social media
series so inside of the social media
series we've already walked through uh
how to increase your instagram
engagement that was with our friend um
chalene johnson we then walked through
how do you do reels and how do you
dominate with reels that was with brock
johnson and then we had one of our
success star students inside of inner
circle one of our mastermind students
ben azadi who taught you exactly how you
could be growing your social media
without having to waste time and lose
your mind because he's able to create
one piece of content that then scales
into other pieces of content so all of
that for our inner circle members is
inside of your membership uh inside of
your membership inside of inner circle
now i'm excited to welcome my friend
rachel miller now let me just tell you a
little bit about rachel rachel is a
serial entrepreneur and serial online
entrepreneur and a mom of six kids hello
thank you i love seeing other moms out
there winning the game of business uh
rachel actually began as a mom blogger
and went on to build an audience ranging
in the millions she is a published
author of multiple books that each uh
have sold more than a hundred thousand
copies and have been featured um live on
good morning america as well as in other
national magazines and syndicated shows
now in january
of
2017 she began teaching others which is
what i love you do the thing first and
then you teach the thing right that's
what we teach you to do here um she
started teaching how people could craft
their viral content um and she's helped
over 27 000 businesses grow in their
engagement 49 of those business
individuals post their individual posts
listen to this have been in front of
more than 10
million people hello 10 million people
with the strategies you're going to
learn today in this exclusive training
with rachel i want to bring my friend
rachel on today and welcome her to inner
circle hey guys so glad to be here thank
you so much heather
i appreciate you for uh for that lovely
announcement
it's always so fun right when people
read your bio you're like did i do all
of those things
it's fascinating for sure um yeah so
i've been super grateful to have been
able to build a multi-million um member
like multi-million people that follow me
and some of them don't even know that i
exist so like they don't know it's
rachel that's running this audience and
the power of that audience though has
changed not just my life but so many
lives and um built so many businesses
for myself and for others and i'm super
grateful to be here today to show your
people what's possible when you have an
audience i am giddy okay so here's what
i need to tell everyone first you need
to cut out distractions my slack has
been going up i'm going to cut down
slack cut down your distractions because
what rachel's gonna bring to you in the
next 30 to 45 minutes is going to be
pure gold for you growing your facebook
page and here's what she's going to be
teaching she's going to teach you how to
work smarter not harder that's what i
need rachel i need to learn how to do uh
working smarter not harder with the
systems that we can learn to that will
help us lead to more sales um for our
facebook content so get your notebooks
out get yourself ready rachel i'm
handing it right over to you oh have fun
thank you guys i appreciate it and
whenever i give examples i always want
to show that it's not just me so i'm not
just the only one who's built an
audience of the millions i've got a
slide here a couple slides to show you
that it's possible for you as well so
there we go okay so it didn't just
happen for me um we've had people just
even in the last month or so cross over
the million fan mark so this isn't
something that happened in the past um
this isn't something that happens like
ages ago and old algorithms this is
something that even kelly has done in
the last couple months and what this is
she's grown a fan base of over a million
people without ads so if kelly can do it
if all the people here can do it guys
you can do it too and you can even do it
if you're a mom
who thinks you're unemployable
who has a van full um if you love people
if you know that your business can make
a difference then this is something that
that you can do now i want to like take
the slide down for a second i want to
show you guys why this is important even
for people on youtube because a lot of
you are like well i'm here for youtube
right i'm here i'm growing my audience
on youtube one of the things about
youtube that i love about youtube is
that it's really stable traffic
really stable what i mean by that in
facebook you have these big giant spikes
you have a spike of traffic and then
guess what happens to that traffic it
dies
okay so facebook has a giant spike of
traffic
facebook then also dies youtube i guess
i should have made the colors different
because youtube totally does red anyways
just note i swapped the colors wrong um
youtube has a sp facebook has this giant
spike of traffic and youtube has a long
traffic
but notice the spike happens all in one
day and it's it's a high spike that
comes that first day so when you post on
facebook more people see it that first
day like
in your audience you can literally get
your post to 10 times your audience size
if you use the right tactics if you have
the right content if you've been
consistent in what we call engagement
stacking so you can reach 10 times your
audience size now knowing that
um in the first day of youtube do you
reach 10 times your size no but you
reach 10 times over time as that post
grows so a post i made four years ago is
still driving traffic because it grows
over time
what if you combine the two together
what i mean by that is what if you take
that youtube
link
this is what's so powerful why i'm super
super excited to be here what if you
spike that traffic
you spike that traffic with facebook or
with one of the the social media
platforms that gives early engagement
you spike that traffic
you're able to raise that ceiling of
where you start with your content so
you're able to get that youtube video to
even more people over time because you
spiked it at the beginning and that's
what's going to be super cool about
today you were here because you're
youtube people and you're going to use
facebook or tick tock or one of the
other spiking platforms to get that
early traction which tells youtube which
tells google with the search engine that
this link is super valuable so from now
on we're gonna send even more traffic to
it than we were previously okay guys i'm
super super excited for this for you
guys
my strategies start with believing that
you shouldn't have to work very hard
how many of you guys are here and you're
a mom um and you're like i'm doing all
of the things like i think of this as a
bring up the slides again real fast i
think of this like um i'm trying to grow
my business and i need to have a sales
page and i need to have a email list and
a facebook group and i have to post that
i put out and i have to be on youtube
and i have to have a lead magnet to go
into that and then i have to have a
challenge maybe or a webinar and i have
to drive all this traffic to it from all
the places and next thing you know i
feel like i need an ads manager a
copywriter a videographer a funnel
designer a group manager okay i'm trying
to do all of the things a scriptwriter
somebody to edit this content i i feel
like i'm needing to do all of the things
and maybe i feel like i'm either leading
a team that's massive and i'm like wait
a second i'm one person in this
orchestra what happened where is my
business or it feels like i'm hurting
cats and i'm like
whoa everybody's it's all running away
from me
i i don't have control over my life
anymore i don't have control over my
business and i frankly i have no clue
what the heck i'm doing because i'm not
a copywriter i'm not a funnel designer
and do not make me do my own customer
service
if anyone else feels like they're being
pulled in all the wrong places
i want you to know that you don't have
to be that there is an easy way and it's
called live looping
oh where did that slide go okay i don't
know where the slide went for that one
guys how many of you guys let's dump it
down how many of you guys have watched
those videos on youtube and it's
somebody and they start playing the
music and they play one instrument like
tap tap tap tap tap and then they add
another instrument sound and then they
add another instrument sound and before
you know it you watch it's one person
but they use a technique called live
looping and as they're playing their
music it becomes a song in time because
they play dun dun dun and then that
plays again and again
and next thing you know it's an actual
song it sounds like it's a whole
orchestra and it's one person but what
one person is doing is they're having
the content loop
now here's what's beautiful you've
already done this if you're listening
here right now in inner circle you have
the content made in youtube already
all you need to do is turn on your
looping system turn on that system that
you play it once and it repeats and it
repeats in a way that stacks on each
other and now you can literally stop
working and see the results happen guys
i made this map i'm gonna shoot the
slide again i made this map literally
this one right here i made this map
right there
six six years ago and it that's that map
right there has run for
six years without me having to remake
the content that is my original here's
what i'm gonna make is my content here's
what i'm gonna cover in one of my
websites that website is earning money
it's earning multiple five figures to
this day without me working on it with
content that i created years ago content
that brings in literally a hundred
million page views to my website and i
haven't worked on it but i am still
promoting it but i haven't made new
content i just have that content on
repeat so that's the system i want to
talk to you right now we're going to
talk about how to make your content
repeat you can pull it on down
the way that you're gonna make your
content repeat is four different steps
one you have to make a bumper sticker
make a bumper sticker two you have to
create a content map
after you create the content map three
you have to batch and bank your work
and then four you need to promote your
work because it doesn't work if you
create the work and you never tell
anybody about it how many of you guys
have done that okay i've literally done
that i've gone on my phone i made a
great video and then i just i guess
forgot it was there or i said i was
going to post it tomorrow and next thing
you know that that work that i did never
saw the light of day because i never hit
publish
you have to promote it and you have to
sell
we're going to take you through these
four steps and then once you have these
steps made you turn it on to a recycling
system
um so you don't have to work as much
anymore you your content goes out to the
world without you having to work for it
it goes out on monday you know what's
going to be posting six months from now
on monday and you didn't have to
struggle to create that content because
it was already made ages and weeks ago
now how many of you are thinking about
this and you're like whoa wait a second
girl this sounds like i'm gonna have to
do a lot of work to set it up
guys my content map
i made it in about 30 minutes
if it takes you more than 30 minutes to
do the content map you're working too
hard on it
so it should take you like 30 40 minutes
to make your content map and then
to create that bank of content
we've literally seen people do it on a
saturday
so if you can give me one day
you can literally invest in your future
audience for their lifetime now i
earlier heather told you that i've had
27 000 people purchase my program
like
me the mom of six kids who thought she
was unemployable has had 27 000 people
purchase my program guys that happened
from work that i did one time years ago
and that's what i want to help you guys
with here today okay
one know your bumper sticker two make
your map three batch and banking because
it doesn't count if you don't have it
organized and then four you have to
actually publish it so it sounds simple
it's easy it does take some elbow grease
but i think you can do it in a single
day so if you're here in the inner
circle group i want you to tag somebody
as like pinky swear that you're gonna do
this together because i don't know if
you're like me i i start something and i
say i'm gonna do it and then i don't do
it um get a partner and literally say
okay we're gonna take ourselves out for
coffee virtually um we'll touch back in
an hour and both of us are gonna go make
our content map let's go do it um go do
that pick a partner and then say okay
we're all gonna do this together on
saturday i'm gonna do it my saturday
you're gonna do it your saturday and
then we're gonna say did you do the work
how many did you do and keep each other
accountable okay
to begin
the bumper sticker that's part one know
your bumper sticker
so i'm getting a marker out here where
did i put my markers
okay
here's my marker we're going to start
with the bumper sticker your bumper
sticker is your i am statement for your
audience
what does your audience call themselves
i am a what
what does your audience call themselves
you have to start with language that
your audience says about who they are
now one of the things in youtube is that
we lot like in youtube to give like
reviews to be kind of educational to go
into like tips and tutorials
facebook instagram tick tock they're
very different
what the person wants when they engage
on facebook when they engage on
instagram they want to make sure that
anything they engage with makes them
look good
so you want to think what not who are
they now
but who do they want to define
themselves as in the future who do they
aspire to be when they go to sleep at
night and they picture themselves in
their best self
what is that person so for me i still
picture myself as a quirky mom i'm a
little weird and i'm a mom
only now i'm weird because i also
collect businesses okay we think what do
we call ourselves
now it's not necessarily what you call
yourself it's what your audience will
call themselves i am a what
know what that is and then when you know
what that is i want you to kind of think
about that journey that your customers
on
they're going from zero
to an amazing day
and along that journey they've got some
steps right they've got some stages
your youtube videos and your social
media content and everything that you're
posting in all of the places needs to
walk them along that journey oh my word
guys i went blurry my camera sometimes
does that sorry about that okay
needs to walk them along the journey so
you're thinking who do they want to
become what is that i am statement i am
at this stage i'm what
okay and then ask yourself along that
journey what things do they need to do
to get along that journey what beliefs
do they have to have
what things do they need to love along
that journey what things are going to
motivate them
what things are they going to have as a
result like a mini result
what things are they gonna have as a
story
okay what i mean by that is like a badge
a story badge like um
like my kids they're in they're in band
and they're in theater and so they all
have a in band they have a story about
the different chairs that they're in so
they have a story about how they've met
this thing or how they dropped their
instrument okay that's a story that
everyone has in that that space it's a
story that when my daughter's talking to
me about the chair she's thinking what
the heck is she talking about because
i'm not a flute and i really don't care
what chair i'm in
does it does it fit my butt can i sit in
it that's about the gist of my my list
of what a story is but that's her story
is what chair she's in so i want you to
think in the language that your audience
would say about what their stories that
they're telling themselves what
obstacles are they facing
okay what proof
do they need to tell themselves they've
made it
this is all the content that you're
going to be creating now in youtube you
already have some videos so let's say
you have a video of a review of a
product awesome
when you're promoting that review
how can you promote it with a story
how can you promote that review of a
product with a motivational statement
how can you promote it with a we're
going to overcome this obstacle that
you're in how can you promote it with a
belief a manifesto like oh my word i
believe this about myself once you have
those sorry guys i move so much and uh
it's fun when you move a lot and this
also tells you you don't have to be
perfect when you're making videos um
that's something on especially social
media on facebook on instagram tick tock
they do not want perfection um and
that's one of the fun things once you
have your your journey next thing you
have to do is make your map
i like to make my map a little bit messy
because i'm not an organized person in
the sense i i'm one of those chaotic
people who who is creative and always
thinking of ideas so my map looks like
this things i love
stories
so remember all those things that we
mentioned obstacles
um we've got beliefs
okay we've got myths that they need to
break we've got tips
okay i'm gonna make my map of what i'm
going to write about what my content is
going to be what my audience needs to
know so that they can be successful what
are some myths that they have about the
niche so i believe that video should be
perfect that's a myth i'm going to crush
it you don't need to be perfect i
believe that all videos must be 10
minutes long no actually 15 seconds is
the real hit right now at least on tick
tocks reels and uh youtube shorts right
i believe that anyone can do video
marketing even if they've never um they
don't want to dance ever
on social media ever that's me i i don't
dance
so i believe what are those beliefs that
they have what obstacles are they
overcoming they don't have money for
equipment um what tips can you give them
so you're gonna make your map and you're
gonna list as many stories that your
audience has dealt with
and when you're wondering is this a good
story always go back to your i am
statement is the story about legos that
you're telling something that all of
your audience would understand
if yes then tell that story if they
would not get the joke then don't tell
it because it has to only relate to your
perfect people only relate to those i am
people what things do your perfect
people love that other people don't love
i love email deliverability because
that's something that as a business
owner i really really care about if i
tell my husband about email
deliverability he's not a business owner
he doesn't really care too much about
being an entrepreneur he doesn't get it
right so what are those things that only
your perfect person loves what are those
tips that only your perfect person will
go bonkos for
this guys becomes your content now my
guess is some of you already have videos
on youtube that cover these things that
are covered that are that you can match
a belief to you can match stories to
that's awesome because you're going to
create content on facebook on instagram
on all the other places especially
facebook because that's where my jam is
you're going to create content there
that drives people to your youtube
channel to watch the long lesson the the
full video okay and when you do this now
face youtube gets that spike and youtube
then says oh you drove so much many
people to this video it must be super
valuable so we're going to increase its
likelihood of being found in searches
because we got traffic coming into us
with
posts that have this keyword in it and
it's the key word that people are
searching and it's the key word that
this video is so this must be a really
valid search result okay guys um
so you've got your map the first thing
you need to do is know your bumper
sticker that's the i am statement know
the bumper sticker that your audience
wants to say second thing you need to do
is make your content map
we've showed you how to make the map
i would love for those of you who are
listening to go take yourselves out for
coffee give yourself a date and make
your maps this should only take you
about 30 minutes because you should know
what things your audience believes what
things that they have as tips that they
should have um there's some hacks if you
need them um actually just pm me if you
need to it's rachel miller on facebook
um big hair you should be able to find
me um
i got a pro cover with six kids on it um
go in there and get ideas i want you to
list as many of these as you can because
the next step is batching and banking
your content okay i guess are you guys
all still with me am i going too fast i
am a fast talker and uh yeah it's just
fun because we want to get like great
results and get it done quickly okay so
next we need to batch and bank
so i look at that map bring up my map
again
bring up display there we go okay and so
i look at my map of content
here it is and i say oh wait let's
actually show you some of the other math
this is a map that somebody who is a
business coach created
this is a map that a doctor created she
teaches doctors so while i showed you my
map it was kind of chaos not everybody's
map is chaos some people's maps are like
this one a nutritionist
or this one i love that one like man i
should have done i should have done mine
in post-it notes i love postmates it's
so pretty
make your map however you need to make
your map but the most important thing is
that you made it and then look at your
map
each one of these post-it notes she has
a content idea on so all the red ones
are things that she loves all the yellow
ones are stories actually those are her
proofs next one the orange ones are her
tips she's teaching tips and solutions
for problems over this one um uh wins
here's stories that people how they've
overcome an obstacle so each one of
those post-its is a different topic
what she needs to do next is to pick up
her phone
literally pick up her phone
and go to that topics and say i'm going
to make a photo for each one of these
so she has the list she's going to take
her list and do number one
one is oh my word the dogs are going
bonkers down number one is this number
two is this number three so she numbers
all of the options and then as she goes
through her numbers she's going to take
photos
so number one
sorry guys my dogs are going bonkers i
don't know what's going on takes the
camera out and makes a photo of her
whatever it is she's gonna take a photo
of it right now so one photo
two the next thing go around the house
go around your life and take a photo my
guess guys is you already have photos in
your life in your business that match
that journey okay so thinking of like
let's say you're in fitness let's say
you're in fitness and you've got things
that they love they love
having extra space in their jeans um
they love a belt buckle going down right
that they don't need the belt much they
have a story of the diet yo-yo so you
can take a picture of something that you
hated when you were dieting you could
take a picture of the jeans you can take
a picture of one of the myths that you
can't have ice cream so you show the ice
cream ball you can take a picture of
each one of the things on this list
now what i would love for you to do is
to think of a youtube video that you've
already got running that you can then
link to so when you post this in your
facebook feed in your instagram channel
you then tag your page and say hey guys
we've got this in our youtube channel
we've got this over here where you can
learn more take the full the full
content okay so now how do we actually
bank bring it back up and we're going to
go into the actual banking
what i like to do after i go through i
like to go and put everything into a
folder so we go onto google drive and i
open up a folder in google drive and i
drop all of my photos into that folder
so you can see here here's a photo of my
my kids closet i've got a photo of me
holding books a photo of my water bottle
okay i went through my list and i took
as many photos as i could i even went to
my audience like this one right here i
went to my audience and said hey can you
share some of your photos so um arena
here showed how she her son and i said
this mom his mom just got to two million
views um on her her two million shares
on her content i took a picture of josh
he sent me a picture of his stuff so i
asked my audience even to give me photos
that i could share featuring them um so
anyways i collected all my photos what
do i do next
collect all my photos we also do the
same thing for video guys so just like
we collected photos we also want to
collect videos but what do we do next we
put them into drive
and then we write the content
how many of us have taken the photos
have taken the videos and then we
stopped there and we don't do the
finessing okay this is actually like for
me it's actually the hardest part
because i don't like writing i don't
like writing so what i found that makes
this stage super super easy and super
super effective is that i get out my
phone and i use an app called
author.ai it's a completely free app or
i use the free version maybe there's a
paid version i use the free version and
i turn on the microphone and everything
that i say that comes out of my mouth
the microphone transcribes into words so
i'll go to my batch and i'll say photo
number one
i went to the store and it was so cool
to see what happens
this is a tip we're covering in our
youtube channel today click for more
okay
next two
okay so the other day i was eating and i
had this thing and the myths that people
believe blah blah blah and this is proof
that it's
it's possible for you
three i go through my list and i
literally say each one of the things and
i just speak into my app
no this is something people always say
to me rachel how come your
words like your
writing seems like like you're talking
to me
it's because i'm literally talking i'm
not writing those things out i'm
speaking them and then i take the app
and i copy and paste it into a
spreadsheet
once it's in the spreadsheet guys
now it's a copy and paste system
um we typically most of the people who
help me with my social media do not
speak english they don't live in my
country
and it doesn't matter that they don't
speak english and live in my country
because all they're doing is copying
that cell of the wording and they're
pasting it onto the platform they're
taking number photo number whatever
video number whatever and they're
uploading that video number into the
platform and they hit publish
that's it this is how this becomes a set
and then forget social system you truly
can promote your content but what make
the content one time and recycle it
again and again and again for literally
life
now all those videos that you've created
you're able to drive traffic to them
using facebook using one of those social
engines that spike the traffic causing
your youtube to actually get more search
results in the end because more people
came to it and then youtube says oh this
is important and you you see those
results now one of the little
tips i have for you is if you're doing
this to spike your youtube chat traffic
try to make sure that in your phrase you
use part of the the youtube
like description what you want it to
appear in search make sure that's in the
first like three lines
you don't always want it in the first
line because people
you need like a hook some some type of
engagement like
cash to capture their attention
so you may not want it in the first line
but you're going to want that search
phrase in there because google the
search engine sees that phrase coming in
with your link to your youtube video and
then
says hey youtube it came in with this
search phrase so now you've increased
your likelihood of coming up in search
so it's a little hack for you i love to
use that same phrase to help my search
engine search traffic so once we have it
we've got our bumper sticker we've made
our content map we've batched it which
meant we took our phone and we took all
the photos we took our phone and we made
all the videos we banked them by putting
them into a google drive or into
wherever your system is that you're
tracking um some of my people prefer to
use trello and they put all their videos
as separate cards and trello um they put
all their photos and their photo stream
and trello what wherever you're using as
your system to keep track of your
content you want to not just batch it
which means you take all the photos at
one time and all the videos at one time
you also want to bank it which means you
put it somewhere and you organize it
whenever i upload them i post them one
through whatever so
my next photos i will post might be 87
97 98 or 98 99 100 101.
i title them with a number so that way
they can go into the spreadsheet and i
can write all that content it's ready to
go
then we want to promote the posts so how
many of us are wanting to grow on
facebook and we're wanting to grow on
youtube
one of the best ways to grow is by cross
promotion so that's how we're
growing our youtube channel because
we're driving traffic from facebook to
youtube but just like youtube wants to
see those incoming links facebook and
all the other platforms they want those
incoming links too
so i love to take every piece of content
that i ever post
anywhere whether i post it on youtube or
post it on pinterest i want to make sure
every single piece of content is
cross-promoted in another place so i
might promote it by driving the link
over if email i might drive a link over
email i might share it into a facebook
group my group or even another person's
group if it's relevant and they don't
see it as spam i might share it over
messenger
or over chat
i might um give my own post a like
because if i don't like my own contact
content why should somebody else like it
i might give my own post a thumbs up i
might tag a friend who needs that
content right i might tag him i'll post
um see somebody that left a reply and
then i'll reply back with a question and
that then leads to a back and forth
dialogue um i'm gonna save my own post
so once you've created your post piece
of content on facebook or wherever that
platform is you want to engage with your
content just like i've listed ways to
engage here another fun thing to do is
to embed it
embed it into a blog post um so guys i
want you to share your content a second
time promote it a second time engage on
it when you do this you're giving the
platform signals so i'm telling facebook
this post that i posted on facebook is
worth liking and people just like me
should like it i'm telling facebook it
should be in facebook groups the people
in this facebook group should see this
post that i just made but also people um
in this group should see other types of
content that i create because they're
similar to my audience um this content
is so valuable it's getting back and
forth interactions so facebook you
should show this content to people just
like the people talking on this so this
is how guys we're able to see content
reach 10 times the people that follow
the page
pull up the slides one more time and i
to show you guys what happens when
you're consistent with this
okay so here um i told you that you want
to ask an im statement so we asked our
audience an im statement we got our
audience to give us ideas
we create the content we create the
content you know you're a graphics
designer when there's 50 shades for the
color purple the result of this guys the
results when you do this is that you're
going to have your audience pay
attention
this girl that posted this only had 200
fans on her facebook page she only had
200 fans and yet
she was able to reach 2 000 people so 10
times her audience
and she was able to get 200 comments on
that post and she was able to do that
with a single post when she only had 200
fans
why because she posted the right content
and she posted it to the right audience
she posted it when it was something
about their journey about who they are
and where they are in the journey and
she posted it and then um promoted it
she promoted it by giving facebook the
signals that said hey this content is
worth seeing this content is super
valuable guys when she can do this um
and she can grow so can all of you um
we've seen uh another gal in here let me
see if i can find her oh where did it go
oh guys there was another girl in here
let me see if i can find her
um she started this and she within four
months she was able to 10x her entire
audience because it's not something that
you do once it's something you can bluff
it back down again it's not something
you do once it's something that you're
going to do again and again and again to
get results so while you start posting
your content today you're like okay i'm
live looping i'm i'm posting a photo i'm
posting a video i'm posting a
conversation starter about this content
i'm posting the math those things that i
believe those things that i love those
stories that everybody in my niche has
and i'm linking to my youtube videos i'm
not seeing results today
those results start stacking on each
other and little by little just like in
youtube where you you post consistently
next thing you know you have this ground
swell of people ready to see you ready
to take your post from 200 to 2 000
people in a single post in 24 hours time
um it happened for her it can happen for
you guys and the steps once again to
recap one know your bumper sticker what
is that statement that your audience
desperately wants the world to know
about them i am a what this makes your
content shareable if your content's all
about you if it's all tips and stuff
that's content that's great for search
but that's not content that gets people
to share that gets people to instantly
engage
then you have to make your content map
sounds crazy um looks messy but frankly
it's absolutely life-changing for you
and for your audience because now they
know what to expect from you and you
don't have to work as hard because the
work was done once then you have to
batch it it's not enough to make the map
you have to actually get your camera out
and make all the content and i love to
take the friction away so i love to use
just my webcam i love to just use my
phone i love to keep it really really
basic because the point isn't um the
fluff and the fanciness the point is
that i got content out there to the
world that's making a difference in
their lives so i batch as quickly as i
can um 80 20 what's gonna the 20
of my effort that's gonna get the eighty
percent of results
batch it bank it and for me that means
putting it into a spreadsheet and using
otter to create the content that i that
the words that that content is then i
promote it how do i promote it i engage
i show my audience what they what
behavior to engage i show facebook what
i want my content to look like and to be
like by engaging in my own content when
i do this guys i'm able to grow my list
grow my leads grow my sales and um okay
i did it all in 40 40 something minutes
just like i promised
oh my goodness rachel that was
amazing i was taking notes the whole
time i was like i got my content map
going i don't know if you can see this
but i was like who okay who is my i am
statement
content map because guys the the
learning doesn't stop this is all part
of the entrepreneurial journey and just
so incredible so rachel thank you so
much for that uh training that part of
the training and um because you know we
want to make sure that people can get
access to you um at a deeper level uh we
want to send them to uh think social
system
that will be a way that they can go
deeper with you and really learn more
about what you're teaching because we
crammed as much as we could in for that
45 minutes um they can go here what can
they expect on the other side of this
think thinksocialsystem.com inside of
that we actually give you the
spreadsheets and we'll give you the
actual like content map so if you're
like one of those people who's like
could i just fill in your system and get
it done faster without having to like
mentally gymnastics this we give it to
you the step-by-step thing and then we
even give you here's your content map
here's your content calendar here's your
content everything and forgive me my
child is knocking the door guys i'm on a
call there is
they all came up from school so they're
uh
anyways okay so yes it's inside there we
have all of the details um it's step by
step by step um we do cover it quickly
but that's because i truly think people
overthink this and it should take you
like 30 minutes to make your map and it
should take you
a day or two days
to batch your content because if it's
taking you longer than you're
overthinking it it's the point is not to
make um it's not youtube is meant for
that production and that's the
difference between youtube and facebook
facebook just your place to promote what
you've product produced so get it
get in and get out as fast as you can is
kind of my my motto okay i'm gonna take
that to heart because i am i am a
struggling perfectionist rachel and i
want it to always look perfect and
always be perfect and so i'm gonna take
that to heart i'm gonna take the
challenge think inner circle i want you
to take the challenge this weekend and
make your map let's make our content
maps and post them
inside of the inner circle group because
i want to share those with rachel um so
the so we can do this as uh as a
collective group and if you're part of
the think fam and you're watching right
now on the youtube channel post it and
tag rachel and myself on social media
tag us so that we can see your content
maps well we are going to jump into the
second part of our think inner circle
and if you want to jump in and be a part
of what we're doing here at think media
on a deeper level um helping you grow
your online business you can join us at
thinkinnercircle.com for the monthly
membership this gives you exclusive
access to our friends like rachel and
brock johnson and chalene johnson and
ben azadi the people that have been a
part of what we're doing this year in
the last part of last year and so many
other incredible expert friends who we
bring into our inner circle and here's
the thing when it comes to being a
trainer or an expert that we bring in
you know it's not just about the
receipts it's not just about you know uh
how are they doing in business to us
here at think media we want to bring
people to you just like rachel can i
just also say i love so much that her
dog was barking that her kids came home
because guys that's a real life like
this is this is just real life doing the
work and it it makes it so amazing to
not have to like think about being
perfect uh when you're doing all of the
things so if you want to go deeper with
our expert friends like rachel who when
we vet them it's not about just the
business it's about what they're
building it's about the integrity of the
person it's about that they're building
something and helping people on a much
deeper level and that's exactly who
rachel miller is you can follow her over
on social media you can go to um think
innercircle.com if you'd like to have
access to the second part of this
training where we're gonna go deeper in
uh in answering your questions having
some hot seats where you can come on
live and ask us questions but if not
we'll catch you in the next video you
can click or tap the screen right now if
you're on youtube and we'll catch it in
the next one